PROFESSOR: OK.
Here we are.
We've got our data.
We've managed to plot it.
Now let's go about
constructing a matrix which
will enable us to fit a
polynomial to this data.
First of all, I need a matrix.
Here is a way to
construct a matrix.
We put s equal to-- The function
zeros is a function which
produces a matrix
with all zeros in it,
and I want this matrix to
have dimensions endpoints
by endpoints.
So this command should
produce such a matrix,
and lo and behold, it does.
Let me just clean up this
display a little bit.
At the moment, it's
a little bit annoying
that I'm plotting out absolutely
everything that I have.
This won't be too much trouble
when I only have six points,
but it might be in
a lot of trouble
if I had a lot more points.
Here's how to stop our MATLAB
or Octave from printing out
the results of a command.
All you do is you
put a semicolon
at the end of the
line, like that.
Or, like that.
If I make that change,
so you hit and run again,
it no longer prints out x and y.
It's still doing the plotting,
and it's printing out s
as being zeros of
endpoints endpoints.
That's not terribly
interesting either,
so I'm going to put a code
on at the end of that line
and prevent s from
being printed out.
Now, zeros is not what I want.
What I want is a matrix which
has the appropriate values
to enable me to fit polynomials.
And those values I'm going
to generate by using a loop.
In general, it's not a great
idea within MATLAB or Octave
to use loops, but it's
perfectly possible to do so.
Loops are generated
in the following way.
Supposing I choose i to
be the index of my loop,
I can let i range
from one to endpoints
by writing 4i equals
1 Coulomb endpoints.
The end of that for loop is
indicated by writing end.
Actually, in Octave, it's
endfor, but in MATLAB it's end,
and so I'm just going to put
end and that works in Octave
as well.
So that would loop
over one index,
but actually I want two indices.
So I'm going to put another
loop inside of the first loop
that I had and I'm going
to make its index j
and I'm going to let it also
run from one to endpoints.
And I need to end
that loop, too.
Let's do my
indentation neatly so I
can understand this loop when
I come back and read it later,
and now that's a loop
which will loop over all
of the indices of the matrix s.
To refer to a particular
element of the matrix s,
I write s of i and j,
where i and j are indices.
So I'm going to set
the ij-th element of s
equal to an appropriate value
to use for polynomial fitting,
and that value is x--
actually x I have to refer to
by its index, so that's xi--
and I'm going to raise it
to the power j minus 1.
So if j is 1, which
is the lowest element,
this would raise it to the 0
power, which would just give me
the result of being x
to the 0, which is 1,
and for higher powers, it
would go on appropriately.
I don't want to print
this out at every time
that I calculate
it, so I'm going
to end the line
with a semicolon.
And then at the end,
perhaps I do want to see s,
so let me just write s, and that
will cause s to be printed out.
So here I am.
I run it again, and now
s consists of this 6
by 6 matrix whose values,
if I look at the top line,
you can see that--
Well, first of all,
let's look at the first column.
The first column is all
the values of j equals 1,
and they're all x to the 0.
And then this next column
is x to the power 1,
so you can see that it
ranges from a 6 to 1.
The next column is
x to the power 2,
and so it runs from a
smaller value up to 1.
So of course all the values
along the bottom row are 1,
and the values along the top
row are 1/6 to the power 0,
1, 2, 3, and so forth.
So that's my s and that's what
I'm going to use as my matrix.
Now, I can take the
inverse of s by writing
some new variable name.
I'm going to call
it sinv to remind me
that it's the
inverse of s, and put
it equal to a function
which is called inv, which
stands for inverse, called s.
So this command finds me
the inverse of the matrix s.
And when I run that,
I find that s inverse
is given by this matrix
here, whose values will
be very hard to guess.
Now, the way to find
the coefficients
of a polynomial fit
to my original data
are to put those coefficients
equal to the matrix product
of the inverse of s, which is
sinv times the y values, which
we learned about in the lecture.
So that would give
me the coefficients.
When I run that, I find
out what the coefficients,
or the different
powers, of x are.
So in other words,
these coefficients--
the first line is the
coefficient of the power x
to the power 0, the next one
is x to the power 1, and so on.
So I've actually found the
coefficients of the fit.
For the moment, it's not obvious
whether I've done it correctly.
I could certainly
plot out the values
of this fit at various
places, and that's
what I'm going to do.
I'm going to plot it
actually with more points
than I started with.
So let me define a
new parameter, np2.
I might make it equal
to, let's say, 40.
I could then have a
second variable, x2,
equal to something
running from 1 to np2
transposed, divided by np2.
So that will be an x array
running from a small value
to 1 with, in this
case, 40 steps.
I'll set, for now,
y2 equal to x2.
That's just created
an array that
is of the same length as x,
and is actually equal to x,
but I'm actually going
to end up setting y
to be something
else in a minute.
And let me, for now, put fj,
a new variable, equal to the c
that I've just calculated.
This won't do
anything interesting,
because I've commented those
out, and so when I run it,
I just get the same
result that I had before.
So I haven't actually
done anything.
Now I'm going to have another
couple of nested for loops.
I'm going to say for j equals
1,np2, and for i equals 1:np2.
Let's f set the
value of fj, which
is a matrix of the vector,
strictly speaking, column
vector of the same length as c.
Let's set that the i-th element
of that equal to the x value,
which is x2, because this is the
second array that I'm creating,
evaluated at parameter j
to the power j minus 1.
So that's actually evaluating
x2 to the appropriate power.
So it shouldn't
have been j minus 1.
It should have been i minus 1.
So this is x2 j
to the i minus 1.
Again, I don't want to
print all of those out,
so I'm going to put a
semicolon at the end.
So that's calculated
by fj value,
and now I'm going to put y2
of j equal to-- Well, what
I basically want to do is form
the dot product between c,
the coefficients,
and the value of fj
that I've just calculated.
So I want c1 times fj1 plus
c2 times fj2 and so forth.
One way of doing
that-- there are
various different
ways of doing it--
is to take the transpose of c.
C remember, is a column vector.
Let's transpose it.
That's going to give
me a row vector.
I can then take the
product of that row vector
with the column vector fj.
And so taking to the
matrix product of a column
vector times a row vector
is equivalent to taking
the dot product of two vectors.
So that has produced
a value y2 of j,
which is equal to the sum of the
coefficients times the values
of x to the appropriate power.
So that's what I want
to form in that matrix.
Again, I'm--
It seems as though
I've made a mistake.
And I'm not quite
sure what I did wrong,
but I need to find out.
So let's have a look.
It's saying that I made my
mistake at line 29 of column 8.
29 is this, and it's saying
that I have a 1 by 6,
and op2 is 40 by 1.
I don't know why
that is 40 by 1.
I'm a bit surprised
by it, because-- Ah.
I see what I did wrong.
This should have been endpoints.
So what I did was,
this inner for loop
shouldn't have been over
all of the j values.
The j values refer to the
length of the new vectors
that I produced.
It should've been over
the shorter version.
So let's see.
Let's save that and hope
that's corrected my error.
Yes.
Lo and behold, it has.
I haven't actually done anything
to show what the result is,
but at least now
I've got the result.
Now what I want to do is, I want
to plot these two new matrices,
x2 and y2, and actually
I'd like to overplot them
on my old plot.
If I just say plot like this,
save this and plot it again,
that isn't what happens.
Instead, what happens is
just the curve that I've just
calculated is plotted, and my
previous plot is wiped out.
What I can do to prevent that
happening is to say, hold on.
Only MATLAB slash Octave
would have something like hold
on as a command.
But anyway, hold on basically
says, retain the data
that you've already got in this
plot and add some more data on.
So let's try this.
So now what we see is the
data that I've plotted out
in my first plot, which
was up here, is held
and the second plot is plotted.
Notice that this fit does
indeed go through the six points
that I originally
retained, and yet,
that line actually
does some funny things.
Particularly at the end
here, it goes negative.
There's another trick that
one can do in plotting,
and one can say things
like axis manual,
and I think that, if I'm
lucky, that will fix this plot.
No, it won't.
Never mind.
Anyway, there's a way--
and I'll show it later--
to prevent the plot rescaling
and the required command
is axis manual.
But at the moment, I
think, before I do it,
I've got to say hold off.
And then if I re-run it, I
will find that lo and behold,
I've got a plot of the
six points and the line
that I fitted, which
is a polynomial fitted
to those lines.
And lo and behold, it fits.